[Musique]
bonjour à tous les connaisseurs les
passionnés d'histoire ou simplement les
fidèles clients qui avaient l'habitude
de venir passer du temps dans ce lieu
périard mois cet édifice que vous avez
certainement reconnu
devant lequel nous nous trouverons
posées sur les quais de seine au coeur
de paris et bien oui il s'agit de la
samaritaine magasin mythique 16 ans
après sa fermeture
alors suivez moi je vais vous raconter
cette histoire de cette rénovation
titanesque que vient de subir la
samaritaine après leur saison de
fermeture et pour m'accompagner
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés jean
françois l'agneau bonjour jean françois
l'agneau bonjour vous êtes architecte en
chef des monuments historiques et vous
êtes avec nous pour nous raconter
l'histoire de cette transformation
jean-françois l'agneau nous sommes à
l'extérieur de la samaritaine avec cette
façade emblématique qui est la façade
par laquelle on identifie d'emblée la
samaritaine
on va faire un petit peu d'histoire elle
remonte à quelle période de l'histoire
cette façade
cette façade elle remonte à 1928 on est
en pleine période de l'art décoratif et
cette façade en fait d'imposer des gros
problèmes administratifs
parce que à l'origine ernest cognacq et
son architecte franz jourdain voulait
absolument continuer les façades qu'il
avait déjà réalisé au début du 20e
siècle et il ya eu un blocage complet de
la part de la ville de paris et
également des associations de défense du
patrimoine qui ne voulait absolument pas
avoir les fasse les mêmes façade
polychrome que qu'il y a que l'on n'a
pas avoir tout à l'heure donc en fait
ernest cognacq a fait appel à un
architecte réputé henri sauvage pour
réaliser cette façade qui n'est qu'une
façade décoratives à l'intérieur on a
exactement la même structure et les
mêmes éléments que dans les parties
réalisées au début du 20e siècle
il était considéré comme comme novatrice
cette façade là comme innovante moderne
aubin henri sauvage était un architecte
réputé dans cette dans cette période et
en fait on a une architecture tout à
fait caractéristique de ce qu'on appelle
l'art décoratif c'est à dire avec des
pans coupés
ça c'est la grande caractéristique des
formes simples stylisé non on est tout à
fait conforme à l'esprit du temps
alors pour ceux qui qui aimait
fréquenter la samaritaine ils se
souviennent certainement qu avant sa
fermeture en 2005 pour des questions de
sécurité bien
cette façade abriter le magasin on
pouvait il faire son shopping on va dire
désormais dans quelques mois
eh ben cette façade n'abritera plus le
magasin à proprement parler mais un
hôtel de luxe hôtel cheval blanc on en
voit d'ailleurs certaines chambres à
travers les fenêtres et on est surpris
parce qu'il n'ya plus le le nom de la
samaritaine qui s'affiche sur la façade
ben ça c'est une surprise on ne sait pas
encore comment va qu'elle l enseigne qui
va venir à cet endroit là effectivement
tout à fait à l'origine il y avait
marqué samaritaine du fait de la
présence de cet hôtel
cette enseigne va être transformée et on
attend de savoir à quoi elle ressemblera
c'est une surprise c'est une surprise
alors vous avez cité évoqué une autre
façade une façade historiquement plus
ancienne que celle que l'on vient de
décrire
qu'est ce qu'une façade que l'on va
aller ensemble découvrir le feu est vert
profitons-en
une façade entre non plus colorés mois -
sobre que vous allez nous décrire
jean-françois l'agneau lé rue de la
monnaie
et on voit déjà le public qui s'est
pressé en masse ce matin pour entrer
dans cette samaritaine rénové on va se
placer au milieu du bosquet si on peut
considérer que c'est un bosquet recettes
espaces verts qui fait face donc à cette
façade plus anciennes qui la façade art
déco que l'on vient de décrire
alors que s'organise
l'arrivée des du public et des visiteurs
ce matin devant l'entrée de cet
samaritaine qui rouvre ce et c'est un
grand jour pour les salariés
le personnel de la samaritaine
jean-françois lannion va s'avancer un
petit peu nous voici là devant la façade
très colorés des types art nouveau
c'est ça alors là on est tout à fait
dans la période art nouveau à la fois
par les par les couleurs par le style
par l'exubérance et encore ce n'est pas
la façade qui avait été réalisée au
début du 20e siècle
parce que le la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres c'est à dire la
période de l'art décoratif avait tout
fait pour effacer justement 7,7
polychromie qu'ils considéraient comme
agressive
ce qui fait que l'ensemble de tous ces
panneaux que vous voyez avait été en
fait pas semblant tout simplement les
les décors à rez-de-chaussée avaient été
supprimés remplacés date par des pierres
tout ça pour s'harmoniser avec le avec
l'art déco alors ces décors avaient déjà
été remis en valeur il ya dans les
années 80 mais en fait nous nous avons
continué de les remettre en valeur sur
toutes les façades qui n'avait pas été
le cas jusqu'à présent
et là en fait on voit parfaitement ce
qu'était le lard nouveau avec avec
toutes les pampres avec les coloris etc
etc
et c'est ça que n'avait pas supporté les
parisiens de l'entre-deux-guerres
alors on a l'impression que c'est de la
simple peinture mais j'imagine que ça
n'est pas le cas de tels matériaux et
constitue
et cette bande d'eau dans les tons
jaunes ses camaïeux de jaune et de
fluides et florales ça aurait été de la
peinture en fait ça n'aurait pas réussi
à traverser le temps puisque ça fait
presque 150 ans en fait ce sont des lave
émaillée
c'est à dire ce sont des émaux qu'ils
sont cuits à très haute température et
qui de ce fait sont absolument
inaltérable et c'est pour ça que il
avait été recouvert en blanc parce
qu'autrement ils se seraient ils les
auraient détruit sans aucune difficulté
et c est un des reproches qui a été fait
également à cette façade c'est que vous
pensez pas le premier des grands
magasins à paris il y en avait d'autres
derrière nous nous avons la belle
jardinière ou on voit en fait que ces
magasins de l'extérieur gardait une
façade entre guillemets haussmannienne
c'est-à-dire conforme à l'esprit du
temps et réservant les décorations pour
l'intérieur ici celle inverse on à
ernest cognacq avait demandé à ce que
vraiment ça soit une façade
publicitaires et on le voit enfin on
voit exactement ce qui se passe dans les
rayons derrière chaussures uniforme
nombreux plans amazon puisque à la à
l'époque on les femmes faisait du cheval
non certes dans deux tenues du jour les
intitulés des rixes et les secours se
sont orientés et d'emblée visible depuis
l'extérieur
alors ça nous n'avons pas pu le
restaurer vous ne trouverez plus
d'uniformes derrière cette derrière
cette lave émaillée
évidemment on remarque d'emblée quand on
arrive face à cette façade bien cette
structure métallique qui vous rappellent
avec ses boulons série vers la structure
est faible ce n'est pas un hasard
il fallait aller très vite il fallait
aller très vite il fallait surtout pas
perdre une seule journée de vente est en
fait ce que l'on voit c'est que
l'arrière pensée de cognac et
l'architecte franz jourdain dans ses
mémoires ou dans les articles qu'il a
peut faire le dit bien ce qu'il fallait
absolument s'était attiré le chaland le
séduire et le conserver le plus
longtemps possible à l'intérieur
donc en fait c'est par la décoration
qu'il arrivait à cela et nous verrons
tout à l'heure le jardin d'hiver
on est bien quand on est dans ce jardin
d'hiver donc on reste plus longtemps
alors je vais vous dire quelques mots de
ces de cette structure eiffel
dont on voit voilà les structures qui
habille cette façade avec ses rivets
qu'on retrouve sur la tour eiffel est ce
que c'est du f ace a justement annoncé
de l'esprit eiffel c'est ce n'est pas
l'entreprise dfl qui là qu'il a réalisé
c'est elle je pars de saumon si je me
souviens bien
non ben le métal c'est tout simplement
parce que ça allait vite
donc l'objectif d'aller faire vite qu'à
les faire vite cogné à commencer par
acheter des coeur d'îlot et
progressivement quand il arrivait vers
la façade
il se dépêchait de faire la façade ce
qui fait que cette façade qui apparaît
comme uniforme telle qu'on la voit comme
ça en fait elle se réalise elle a été
réalisée en gros par des tranches de 20
mètres sur une dizaine d'années à peu
près c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
c'est qui encore une fois le la vente
c'est ce qui comptait le plus on
pourrait remarquer également que sur le
logo ci ont tout à fait ça comme ça la
marque samaritaine se met ça n'est pas
le même travail qui a été réalisé que
sur la lave de volvic la bad boys et de
la lave de volvic c'était hôpitaux de la
mosaïque doré à l'or fin si je m'abuse
lassé de la mosaïque essai de la
mosaïque qui est effectivement doré
c'est à dire que il ya une feuille d'or
il ya eu cet été c'est l'envers sur cet
essai l'emmène feuille d'or et on remet
une couche de verre par dessus ce qui
fait que l ocl est inaltérable
est ce qu'on peut considérer que que ses
façades que l'on vient de décrire la
première art déco la seconde art nouveau
ce sont elles sont dans la catégorie des
monuments historiques le bâtiment
lui-même l'édifice est classé monument
de l'ensemble de l'édifice les protégés
au titre des monuments historiques c'est
à dire essentiellement les façades et
les couvertures et ainsi que tout les
tous les éléments patrimoniaux que nous
allons voir à l'intérieur
j'aimerais qu'on dit juste avant à
vendre éventuellement de pouvoir entrer
à l'intérieur aussi pour le public qui
s'est déjà engouffré dans cette
samaritaine qui vient de rouvrir qu'on
dise quelques mots sur ces ses baies
vitrées percée dans la façade est ce qu
elle avait aussi à caractère de
modernité de l'innovation
alors toujours pareil ernest cognacq
s'est servi d'eux des innovations
techniques qui existaient c'est à dire
la construction métallique
l'objectif c'était de faire rentrer au
maximum la lumière du jour
c'était une période où il n'y avait pas
encore l'électricité au tout début du
20e siècle
donc ça ne fonctionnait que par la
lumière du jour donc il fallait des
belles et plus ouverte possible et ne
pas avoir de maçonnerie qui viennent en
réduire le clair selon l'expression et
vous verrez à l'intérieur en faite le
véritable jardin de le jardin d'hiver
qui à l'intérieur dont l'objectif était
de là encore de faire entrer la lumière
naturelle jusqu'au premier sous sol on
attend que le camaïeu de jonin
finalement adouci formidablement cette
structure métallique peut être un peu un
peu sévère c'était une volonté aussi de
peut-être apporter cette touche de
légèreté on va dire
l'objectif c'était vraiment de d'attirer
le d'attirer les chalands come on come
on met du miel pour attirer les mouches
c'est vraiment le ce qui était dit
d'ailleurs dans l'est dans les textes
pas forcément publié d'ailleurs alors la
samaritaine était un temple de la mode
pour ceux qui la fréquentait avant sa
fermeture en 2005 et bien elle est de
nouveau 20 mille mètres carrés de mode
espace totalement rénové on va le
découvrir ensemble on va y entrer dans
cette samaritaine on va cibler public
qui vient d'y entrer et puis on va
continuer à parler d'histoire est
expliqué en quoi consistait cette
rénovation titanesque réalisé sur cet
édifice emblématique
[Musique]
jean-françois lannion on a réussi à se
frayer un passage parmi le public qui
vient d'entrer dans la samaritaine pour
découvrir ce lieu splendide symbolique
aussi de l'intérieur de l'amas de la
samaritaine
je vais laisser rien de vêtir de faire
un panorama de ce qui nous entoure et
filmé la perspective sur le grand
escalier cette fameuse verrière qu'on
dira avoir tout à l'heure on retrouve
évidemment autour de nous les détails
art déco et art nouveau
la ferronnerie repartant grise et ce
gris bleu d'ailleurs était-il la couleur
d'origine des ferronneries qui nous
entoure
j'écoutais ça a été l'une des
difficultés du chantier c'est que vous
imaginez qu'un bâtiment de ceux de cette
qualité et repeint régulièrement tous
les dix ans à peu près donc évidemment
en tant que architecte en chef des
monuments historiques je souhaitais
retrouver là la couleur d'origine du
jour de l'inauguration c'est toujours la
date que l'on recherche et en fait on a
fait ce qu'on appelle des stratigraphie
c'est à dire qu'on a enlevé avec un
scalpel les différentes couches de
peinture qui avait été réalisé et on est
arrivés sur cette couleur
on a été confrontée en fin on était
confirmée dans ce choix par des
autochromes il y avait des photographies
couleur datant de 1910 des extérieurs et
qui nous ont montré qu effectivement on
avait ce gris bleu qui qui est qu'on
appelle maintenant le gris samaritaine
c'est une couleur qui est assez
traditionnel de l' architecture
métallique du de la fin 19e début 20e
elles ont été restaurées ses
ferronneries sur place où elles ont été
démontées pour pouvoir être traitées
rapidement mais massivement on va dire
parce qu'il ya quand même une quantité
de travail considérable à faire
alors en fait non elles ont été démonté
et emporté dans des ateliers ici c'est
un atelier qui est à côté de périgueux
donc elles ont été restaurées et en même
temps il ya eu des recréations parce que
certaines avaient disparu il y avait des
escaliers mécaniques qui avaient été
placés un peu n'importe comment à partir
des années 60 et donc il a fallu
restituer ses ferronneries mais on a
trouvé d un ferronnier sachant
parfaitement forget exactement les mêmes
les mêmes courbes qui sont assez
répétitive et ensuite on a pu redorer
les feuilles des marronniers qui
viennent ponctuer un peu cette cet
ensemble de ferronnerie et 7 ferronnerie
si on la regarde en détail
c'est vraiment des détails d'exécution
absolument exceptionnel c'est
entièrement assemblé à sec par davis
tout bêtement quelque chose qui ne se
fait absolument plus puisqu'on a
tendance maintenant à mettre des
soudures absolument partout non c'est
vraiment un très très bel ouvrage est
tout à fait caractéristique de l'art
nouveau
on imagine la complexité de retrouver
peut-être des artisans à même de
travailler cette matière de cette façon
là aussi exigeante
on en trouve aussi le service des
monuments historiques veille justement à
conserver cette mode en lui confiant des
travaux le plus régulièrement possible
c'est pas toujours c'est pas toujours
évident mais de plus en plus on a des
jeunes qui s'orientent vers ce type de
métiers qui sont durs on voit que le
lieu accueille des grands noms du luxe
autour de nous je ne vais pas les citer
probablement que riyad bekir aura fait
quelques plans sur ses marques au milieu
de ce mobilier d'une autre audition de
sacs à main de portefeuille de grands
noms du luxe pardon c'était 17
esthétique raffinée et chic et éthique
celui de de l'époque
est ce que véritablement on avait une
offre aussi luxueuses à l'époque de
l'ouverture de ce magasin c'est
d'éveiller évidemment ce n'était pas
l'objectif de la samaritaine pour le
luxe on avait la belle jardinière qui se
trouvait juste en face là c'était
vraiment un grand magasin beaucoup plus
populaire en pas si on peut donner un
sens à ce mot vous savez d'où
l'expression trouvent tous à la
samaritaine c'est à dire qu on trouvait
absolument aussi bien des livres et de
domestiques que des détenus d'amazon que
des clous et je dirais jusqu'à ces
dernières années puisque moi ce que je
regrette dans ce nouveau magasin c'est
qu'on puisse lui acheter des clous à
l'unité ce qui était le cas autrefois un
ça c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui la
samaritaine offre en plus la possibilité
d'acheter des produits issus des rayons
plutôt du bricolage ce n'est plus du
tout l'offre
mise en avant effectivement alors on
remarque évidemment quand on arrive dans
ce lieu majestueux c'est la lumière
naturelle qui nous inondent et qui n'ont
de 6 également les étages supérieurs au
dessus de nous est-ce que c'était une
volonté architecturale une volonté
défini à l'origine pour pour mettre en
valeur les lieux sans passer par la
lumière artificielle électrique c'était
plus qu'une volonté c'était une
obligation puisque en fait il n'y avait
pas de la lumière électrique au début du
20e siècle
donc il fallait absolument que le que le
l'ensemble des planchers des rayons soit
illuminée soient éclairés par la lumière
naturelle même le gaz n'aurait pas suffi
à faire un éclairage intérieur deux ans
le gaz est toujours dangereux et on s'en
méfie ponctuellement il y en avait mais
ça ne suffisait pas éclairé correctement
donc en fait on a été obligé de faire
ernest cognacq a été obligé de d'avoir
cette verrière
mais je dirais qu'il ya également
d'autres d'autres intéressés que non
seulement elle apporte la lumière
naturelle
on le verra qui étaient diffusées par
les planchers qui était en verve mais
également sa a permis de réaliser ce
superbe escalier monumental et un
escalier monumental en fait ça participe
à la scénographie de ce genre de magasin
parce que ça entraîne une déambulation
ça permet de lorsqu'on est dessus de
voir l'ensemble des rayons
ça permet également d'être vu ça on a pu
le constater quelques fois et puis
encore une fois c'est c'est quand même
une oeuvre d'art on a cet escalier c'est
vraiment une oeuvre d'art en lui-même et
c'est ça qui est exceptionnel quand on
voit tous les détaillants en cuivre
repoussé en céramique en enfer en
ferronnerie on l'a vu tout à l'heure des
ses feuilles des marronniers qui sont
dorées à leurs fins c'est vraiment une
une oeuvre exceptionnelle et encore une
fois ça participer au bien être des
visiteurs alors jean-françois la nuit
tout à l'heure nous avons le regard nos
regards levés vers le ciel vers le haut
vers les étages supérieurs vers cet
escalier magistral mais il faut regarder
aussi les sols et les seul mérite notre
attention parce qu'il ya un travail
remarquable et fouillé qui a été
effectué sur ces sols est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots de
ceux ci par exemple écouter l'ensemble
de ses soldats était refait tout à fait
à l'origine c'était la veille c'était
des planchers de verre donc on n'a pas
pu les les refaire pour des raisons de
sécurité on en parlera là haut mais on a
essayé de retrouver
je dirais quelque chose qui pouvait
laisser imaginer que c'était qu'il y
avait des carrés de chocolat c'est l
appellation que l'eau que l'on donnait
donc c'est comme ça qu'on ne que ces
sols qui est récent donc qui vient
d'être fait c'est aussi au pavé parisien
peut être assez laissé plein clin d'oeil
en fait le parlaient de l'aménagement
des stands ou autres par définition les
stands changeront alors je sais pas si
c'est tous les cinq ans ou tous les dix
ans ou plus rapidement mais à chaque
fois c'est un clin d'oeil à l'
architecture bas qui existe depuis le
début du 20e siècle
alors on va se pencher il focalisait
notre attention désormais sur ce grand
escalier tout à fait iconiques de la
samaritaine
on va monter les marches de l'escalier
je vous propose que vont m'accompagner
fait partie des éléments architecturaux
incontournable des lieux il n'y a plus
qu'une valeur fonctionnelle c'était ce
qui lui permet de monter certes dernier
étage au cinquième mais là aussi une
valeur esthétique cet escalier
jean-françois l'agneau abaisser la
valeur esthétique avec en fait c'est une
accumulation de petites oeuvres d'art je
ne sais pas ce ne sont pas de ses
grandes oeuvres d'art que l'on met dans
des musées mais ce sont des tas de
petits détaillants canton revoilà la
ferronnerie les assemblages de de tous
et de tous et faire la façon dont ils
sont forgés voyant là on le voit on part
d'une plaque de fer que l'on vient
fendre et ensuite on lui donne la forme
voulue c'est un c'est vraiment un
ensemble de de grande qualité
alors compte l'une de des 270 marche de
cet escalier qui je crois est en chêne
massif d'origine si je me trompe pas
jean-françois lannion on a été obligé de
changer quelques marches quand même
reconnaître parce qu'elle était fatiguée
alors on se trouve sur le palier premier
palier de cet escalier il faut
pour admirer quelque chose que qui a été
révélé je crois au cours de ces travaux
oui c'est ses feuilles d'acanthe en
céramique ses devis également il ya tout
un mélange ça ça a vraiment été une
découverte en cours de chantier
parce que dans les investigations que
nous avions pu faire on avait fait des
sondages
malheureusement il était tombé sur des
parties qui avaient dû être fait en
plâtre et au fil du temps donc on
n'avait pas attaché d'importance à ça et
on s'apprêtait à refaire le plafond
blanc qui était qui et qui existaient
lorsque nous sommes arrivés
et puis en fait en cours de chantier on
a quand même voulu gratter un petit peu
plus pour voir ce qu'il en était et on a
découvert ces superbes céramique
évidemment s'est empressé de les mettre
en valeur absolument partout mais encore
une fois elle avait été dissimulé tout
simplement parce que la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres avait ça absolument
en horreur je laisse à décrire qui
réalisent ces images vous montrer un
petit peu ce qui nous entoure nous
sommes de niveau 1 de la samaritaine au
niveau mode femme
et puis les étages supérieurs
les seront dévoilés aux futurs visiteurs
et à ceux qui sont actuellement entrer
dans la samaritaine l'horlogerie la joie
la mode pour homme les souliers aussi
pour femmes du rayon desquels on peut
admirer une magnifique vue sur l'église
saint germain de l'auxerrois
alors d'içi jean-françois l'agneau va
nous pouvons relier ce bâtiment du pont
neuf jusqu'au un autre édifice thé lady
peace rivoli fait le nouveau bâtiment de
la samaritaine beaucoup plus moderne et
rénové aussi en même temps que celui
dans lequel on se trouve
on va y aller ensemble nous traverse
sept étages dédiés effectivement à la
mode à la mode femme comme je le disais
on va passer par ici on laissera le
public qui nous regardent découvrir le
bâtiment vers lequel on se dirige on
quitte le bâtiment pour neuf pour aller
vers le bâtiment rivoli c'est un
bâtiment de verre qui donne sur la rue
de rivoli et puis les visiteurs qui
voudront aller le voir ne serait-ce que
pour faire du shopping ou le visiter
lors de leur visite parisienne ils y
trouveront une décoration moderne au
style industriel en adéquation avec une
mode plus urbaine on va dire ça ce sont
des considérations un peu plus marketing
que j'évoque avec vous jean-françois
l'agneau alors qu'on arrive dans ce
patio où on peut parler de passion en
tout cas c'est un lieu qui n'existait
pas à l'origine à la samaritaine qui a
été sorti de terre très moderne avec ce
plafond de verre qui évidemment n'est
pas sans rappeler la fameuse verrière
originel et qui laisse évidemment les
lieux baigné d'une lumière naturelle
mais c'est un c'est ce qu'a voulu
l'agencé sana c'est justement de
retrouver l'esprit de de cette grande
verrière que nous venons quitter pour
retrouver ensuite une succession de deux
patios puits de lumière appelons le
comme on veut ici ça s'appelle le dôme
ça s'appelle le dôme est donc comme vous
le voyez
ryad vêtir qui réalisent ces images est
en train de nous montrer ce plafond de
verre moderne en adéquation avec le
bâtiment rivoli qui donne sur la rue de
rivoli et qui lui même est habillé de
verre d'une vague de vers qui on habille
les murs de la façade
face à ces caractéristiques aussi de la
samaritaine
c'est que les propriétaires de la
samaritaine c'est-à-dire ernest cognacq
pour la grande période ont toujours
voulu être à la pointe du progrès en
effet en architecture donc ils ont eu
une architecture typiquement art nouveau
avec franz jourdain
on cite une architecture typiquement art
déco avec henri sauvage et maintenant
avec l'agencé sana sur la rue de rivoli
ils ont une architecture que de notre
temps alors qu on déambule dans cette
dans ce niveau dédié à la mode pour
femmes nous allons arriver sur sur cette
passerelle qui fait la transition entre
les deux bâtiments
que faut-il admirer particulièrement à
cet endroit jean-françois l'agneau je
crois qu'on a une perspective sur une
ruelle qui donne elle-même sur les
façades historiques de la samaritaine on
le voit sur votre gauche
nous sommes effectivement dans cette
petite rue baillet qu'était vraiment une
rue historique on voit un échafaudage
ici c'est sont des immeubles du xviie
siècle qui sont en train d'être ravalée
selon l'expression et en face on se
trouve dans une partie de donc de franz
jourdain 1907 1910 avec vous voyez tout
c'est toutes ces céramiques toutes ces
mosaïques que l'on voie relativement peu
puisqu'on n'a pas de recul donc c'est
pour ça l'intérêt de cette passerelle
entre autres c'est justement de pouvoir
découvrir ces décors qui sont
relativement méconnu on imagine les
difficultés ou la complexité auxquelles
ont dû faire face les équipes engagées
dans la restauration de ces lieux il a
fallu jongler entre les impératifs il ya
l'histoire au respect du bâtiment imposé
par la charte
on imaginer des monuments historiques
aux normes de sécurité également
jean-françois l'agneau et puis les
souhaits du propriétaire en l'occurrence
le groupe lvmh de modifier les lieux de
les moderniser de les adapter à son
projet de transformation est ce que ça a
été compliqué de jongler avec tout ça ça
a été compliqué en particulier alors ça
a été compliqué à deux niveaux au point
de vue technique parce qu'effectivement
c'est une opération c'est compliqué dans
la mesure où sur la partie que nous
voulons quitter il fallait respecter
l'ancien et en même temps apporter les
parties contemporaine que nous avons pu
voir je dirais que c'était des problèmes
techniques que l'on arrive à résoudre
même si c'est compliqué l'autre problème
en fait c'était un problème
administratif d'autorisation de travaux
la question était de savoir peut-on pas
démolir les immeubles qui se trouvait
sur la rue de rivoli
ainsi c'est ce qui a fait d'ailleurs que
le chantier a été retardé de deux années
et puis en fin de compte donc le lvmh a
eu l'autorisation de démolir ces
immeubles
oui c'est une épisode on va dire qu'il
ya eu
droit sa polémique évidemment puisque
pour beaucoup on détruisaient un
monument historique ce n'était pas un
monument historique était détruit les
études patrimoniales que nous avions pu
conduire montré que c'était un c'était
des immeubles vides hier été construit
dans la deuxième moitié du 19e siècle
qui avait déjà été transformés je vous
dirais saccagé à la fin du 19e et au
début du xxème pour mémoire c'était les
fourrures réveillon qui habitèrent qui
occupait cet immeuble et ensuite mon la
samaritaine c'est vrai dans les années
1930 elle aussi avait fait avait apporté
beaucoup de modifications et il ya eu
des surélévations enfin pour nous ça
n'avait plus d'intérêt patrimonial et
donc en fin de compte l'autorisation
était donnée de l'aider me dire donc
désormais pour ceux qui viendront
visiter ce bâtiment rue de rivoli vous
verrez à quel point le contraste est
flagrant entre le bâtiment du pont neuf
hans être rénovés de la samaritaine
et puis ce bâtiment rue de rivoli
flamboyant de modernité le groupe lvmh a
investi plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros pour rénover cet samaritaine
tant attendu mais même quand on
s'appelle lvmh et là je m'adresse à
l'architecte en chef des monuments
historiques bar on ne peut pas faire ce
qu'on veut on imagine
y at il des transformations qui ont été
refusées qui resteront impossible de
toute façon à réaliser parce
qu'interdites par ce que il ya ce garde
fou des monuments historiques qui
protègent les bâtiments ils écoutaient
ce garde fou comme vous dites a été
pleinement efficace puisque vraiment il
a permis il a permis de protéger les
parties patrimonial qui avait été
reconnu par tout le monde et que nous
avons pu restaurer vraiment sans
difficulté nous avons on est
l'architecte est souvent inquiets parce
que elle à cause des appels d'offres
parce que dans les appels d'offres on
prend souvent le moins disant c'est à
dire c'est pas forcément le meilleur
or là nous avons réussi à avoir les
meilleurs artisans d'art possible pour
restaurer les ferronneries les peintures
l'egypte ce riz etc
donc non lvmh je dirais que ça plutôt
été un plus pour lui de pouvoir
conserver ces partis historiques qui
n'est pas été contrarié sur une décision
qu'il aurait souhaité prendre dit
formation à laquelle vous avez dit non
parce qu'on ne peut pas le faire la côte
est il là il avait qu'il n'avait pas le
choix de toute façon et je crois que ce
sera un atout pour ce magasin y at-il au
contraire des découverts qui ont été
faites des découvertes des trésors qui
ont été révélées qu'on ne soupçonnait
pas ou bien qu'on avait peut-être oublié
garras à 7
cet investissement considérable financer
les vm h et puis ces travaux titanesques
il ya deux choses ça a permis deux
choses c'est que d'une part on a pu
obtenir toutes les archives de la
samaritaine on a pu le lait d'éplucher
les éplucher à fond c'est à dire voir
exactement comment ça avait été
construit je dirais presque au jour le
jour
bon on a oublié ce genre de ce genre de
photographies qui montre et gagné
exactement dans l'avancement du chantier
donc depuis quand je dis l'avancement du
chantier c'est depuis 1870 jusqu'à nos
jours
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et un
font photographier vraiment merveilleux
sur la samaritaine
et puis autrement c'est vrai qu'en cours
de chantier on a fait des découvertes
parce que je vous le disais tout à
l'heure la une qui vous a marquée par un
lyonnais qui m'a marqué parce que
vraiment j'étais vexé de ne pas l'avoir
vu avant c'était tout simplement je vous
disais tout à l'heure que la période de
l'entre-deux-guerres c'est-à-dire de
l'art décoratif avait effacé vraiment de
façon drastique
toutes les tout ce qui était à nouveau
c'est parce que l'esprit c'était le
purifier un peu l'architecturé les et
les décorations et donc tout ce qui
représentait tout ce qui était en
couleurs avait été badigeonnés blancs
recouverts de plâtre et en particulier
sous l'escalier d'honneur que nous avons
vu tout à l'heure il y avait des décors
que l'on imaginait absolument pas on
avait bien fait des sondages pour voir
si j'avais quelque chose et puis c'est
le problème des sondages c'est qu'on ne
les fais jamais forcément au bon endroit
et en cours de chantier on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait des céramiques d'une
tonalité absolument exceptionnelle et en
fait on a pu les remettre en valeur
quelle est la partie de ce chantier
titanesque qui a été là la plus complexe
à mettre en oeuvre par sa durée ou par
sa technicité
en gros la difficulté ça a été de faire
travailler des artisans d'art qui sont
évidemment très minutieux dans l'or
dans leur approche des matières et des
entreprises jeudi rafa c'est pas
péjoratif ce que je vais dire mais enfin
qu'ils sont habitués à travailler dans
moins dans le détail ça ça a été assez
difficile alors au début ça a été très
compliqué et puis au fur et à mesure
chacun sait respecter ayant fait les
deux les deux approches du bâtiment ont
réussi à travailler correctement
ensemble c'était compliqué de trouver
autant d'artisans spécialisés dans
parfois des tâches extrêmement complexes
où ils nécessitaient un savoir faire
ancestral je dirais non parce qu'en fait
grâce aux au service des monuments
historiques justement on arrive à
entretenir ses ses artisans
ce qui a été compliqué c'est de trouver
ce que ce qu'on estimait être les
meilleurs pour telle ou telle tâche
alors à propos de trésors et de lieux
magiques je vous propose qu'on monte au
dernier étage découvrir la pépite des
lieux l'emblématique verrière art
nouveau et la fresque dépens on y montre
tout de suite on vous y retrouve jean
françois l'agneau on vient d'arriver
dans ce lieu où dire majestueux
cette verrière au dernier étage de la
samaritaine et encore une fois c'est la
lumière qui est présentée une lumière
qui vient à la fois du ciel si je puis
dire mais également des sols avec ses
carreaux de verre qui reproduisent
j'imagine les planchers d'origine qu'est
ce qu'on peut en dire deux de ses
carreaux de verre sous nos pieds
écoutez en est effectivement dans le
morceau de bravoure de ce magasin le
problème de l'architecte c'était
simplement d' à lui d'apporter la
lumière jusqu'au premier sous-sol
puisqu'on était dans une période on
était au tout début du 20e siècle il y
avait pas l'électricité
donc il fallait absolument que la
lumière naturelle qui se pénétrer dans
tous les niveaux dans tous les étages
absolument partout donc pour ça mais il
avait donc réaliser cette magnifique
verrière que nous avons pu remettre dans
son état d'origine
et surtout tous les planchers et et en
dalles de verre
on appelle ça des tablettes de chocolat
parce qu'en fait c'était fait la pause
insisté ristic et je dirais que ça ça a
été là la seule déception que j'ai eu
pendant ce chantier c'est qu'il a été
absolument impossible de refaire ses
planchers de verre sur la totalité du
magasin ils auraient dû être présents
sur à chaque niveau il était à l'origine
présent dans tous les niveaux aussi bien
dans la partie sauvage que dans la
partie jourdain mais pour des raisons de
sécurité il est absolument impossible de
les refaire on a cherché on a torpillé
le problème dans tous les sens c'était
absolument impossible donc en fait on a
fait ce que j'appellerais un petit clin
d'oeil où on a simplement cessé fameuse
dalle de verre mais elles sont
strictement décoratives elles sont
décoratifs mais elles ont nécessité
j'imagine un travail considérable de
mise en place de haut niveau des
infrastructures et de la sécurité qui
peuvent représenter
l'installation de ce type de matériau
oui bon c'est simplement en fait ce sont
des dalles qui sont posées sur un sur un
plancher en béton pour faire simple donc
je dirais c'est un c'est un petit clin
d'oeil et la samaritaine
ah ben c'est accepter de se payer ce
petit sur coup parce que c'était
vraiment le l'origine et la raison
d'être de ce magasin c'était que la
lumière naturelle puisse pénétrer
jusqu'au sol cette lumière naturelle
qu'on avait évidemment
déjà pu admirer dès qu'on rentre au rez
de chaussée de cette formidable édifice
jean-françois l'agneau en préparant
cette émission j'ai appris que
finalement cette splendide verrière n'a
pas toujours été visible
il fut un temps où elle avait même été
masquée on ne la voyait plus pour
quelles raisons
ah ben ça c'est toujours l'histoire des
des styles des styles d'architecturé de
mode du je dirais tout simplement la
mode par définition de sas des modes et
en fait là on est dans la période on est
dans je dirais la fin de l'art nouveau
et quand l'art déco est arrivé ils
trouvaient ses couleurs absolument
horrible et les formes et exubérante et
autres donc en fait il n'a eu 15 15 je
dirais qu'une qu'un moyen de les effacer
simplement c'était de les peindre en
blanc on l'a vu à l'extérieur tous les
décors avaient été peints en blanc à
l'intérieur c'est pareil et cette
peinture murale avait été entièrement
recouverte de peinture blanche et un
faux plafond venait dissimuler cette
structure métallique qui apparaissait
trop peu pour un garde en fait il faut
dire il faut dire le mot alors on ne
peut pas ne pas évoquer évidemment parce
qu'elle nous saute aux yeux c'est de
cette fresque cette peinture murale
faut-il dire apparemment qui représente
dépendant des jardins alors pourquoi ce
pont d'ailleurs c'est la fresque dépens
pourquoi le choix de cet animal est ce
que vous le savez
ah ben c'est un animal un petit peu
magique que l'on retrouve à travers le à
travers toutes les civilisations ou
autres magique pourquoi parce que là on
le voit bien lorsqu'il fait la roue je
veux pas citer baudelaire mais lorsqu'il
fait la roue il est absolument
extraordinaire
et si on regarde bien on peut voir dans
l'extrémité des plumes se lance on la
façon dont on le ressent sous adecr soin
des yeux et en fait c'est ça qui est
absolument magique dans ce dans cet
animal et puis il se trouve que cette
cette forme en queue de paon selon
l'expression est une forme qui
correspond tout à fait à la période de
le à l'extrémité de l'art nouveau jeudi
l'extrémité de l'art nouveau parce que
cette peinture présente la
caractéristique d'assurer la liaison
entre l'art nouveau et l'art déco on est
plus déjà on le voit dans la végétation
commence à se structurer on ad on a des
traits ya
j'en à des pans coupés ou autre
autrement dit c'est une c'est de l'art
nouveau qui se structurent je crois je
me je me répète et c'est ça qui est
absolument exceptionnel dans cette dans
cette peinture et de fait elle a été
réalisée dans les années 1910 en 1907
1910 et l'art déco on a toujours
tendance à le remarquer de 1925
parce qu'il ya eu la fameuse exposition
mais en fait il est évident que ce style
avait démarré bien avant et c'est une
des qualités de ceux de cette peinture
justement c'est d'assurer la transition
entre les deux styles qui marque la
samaritaine beauté sauvage et côté
jourdain cette frise
permettez moi de dire frise je n'ai pas
les termes techniques et la souplesse la
frise en dessous cette fresque de
peinture 7 cette peinture murale
elle a aussi un sens particulier on voit
des grappes de fruits elle aussi a
nécessité probablement une une
rénovation assez conséquente on imagine
que c'est la feuille d'or que l'on voit
dans l'axé c'est effectivement ces deux
là c'est de la feuille d'or alors ça
imite une mosaïque d'or mais c'est
simplement de la feuille d'or sur lequel
on a dessiné des tesselles pour faire
quoi que c'était de la mosaïque et là on
retrouve tout à fait l'esprit qui a
guidé le franz jourdain l'architecte et
surtout son client ernest cognacq c'est
qu'il voulait faire vite donc mettre des
vrais tesselles ça aurait pris beaucoup
de temps
donc en fait il a mis de la feuille d'or
ce qui permet de transmettre la lumière
c'est un trompe l'oeil on va dire ah
c'est un trompe l'oeil et souvent le
trompe l'oeil a plus de qualités que le
que le vrai c'est ça qui est curieux
autrement on retrouve des des grappes de
raisin de comme les peintres que l'on
avait à l'extérieur etc
on est tout à fait dans l'est dans le
style art nouveau
on devine évidemment on le voit nous
saute aux yeux cette structure eiffel
construit depuis l'extérieur de cet
édifice
là encore c'est une prouesse
architecturale c'est une prouesse
technique je dirais ce sont des des
formes qui qui existait déjà mais c'est
la peau est la véritable prouesse en
fait ça a été la rapidité de mise en
oeuvre
l'ensemble était préfabriqués en usine
on le voit parfaitement tout ce qui est
tout ce qu'ils possèdent des rivets est
effet préfabriqués en usine et ensuite
on l'a porté sur le chantier et on le
boulonnais alors les boulons les voies y
sont ils sont cachés en général mais
donc c'est là la peau est pour moi c'est
une prouesse technique
une prouesse technique alors je crois
que on a aussi du trompe l'oeil dans la
structure eiffel puisque certaines
parties ne sont pas en métal
elles sont en stick c'est ça oui alors
ça ça aussi c'est une des
caractéristiques c'est que l'homme
ernest cognacq ne voulait pas perdre un
jour de vente
il fallait donc aller très très vite et
en fait tous ces éléments que vous voyez
normalement devrait en fonte moulée
je travaille actuellement sur la poste
du louvre où la l'état avait le temps
donc il a fait des ouvrages en enfants
que nous les alors qu'ici il n'avait pas
le temps donc résultat il l'a fait en
plâtre et en fait on ne voit pas la
différence
le seul moyen de voir la différence
c'est facile c'est de poser la main
dessus
quand vous êtes sur le faire c'est froid
quand vous êtes sur le plâtre c'est
chaud évidemment on retrouve le gris
bleu un typique de cette structure
eiffel de la samaritaine qu'on a qu'on a
évoqué un canton est arrivé dans
l'édifice jean-françois l'agneau bien on
arrive à la fin de de notre déambulation
dans cette danse est cet endroit ce lieu
magique exceptionnel ce qui nous entoure
est unique exceptionnel également merci
un de nous avoir éclairé de nous avoir
informés dans les moindres détails de ce
de cette histoire architecturale de ce
bâtiment qui rouvre ses portes
aujourd'hui 23 juin 2021
nous pourrons plus jean françois lanoue
de shopping dans ce lieu sans s'enfoncer
à vous et à ce que vous avez raconté
j'espère que cette visite guidée vous
aura plu autant qu'elle m'a enthousiasmé
aujourd'hui j'ai été séduite par la
beauté des lieux je pense que ce sera le
cas du public acquis dans quelques
minutes
rentrera ici merci enfin à houta via
palombes à et de chez carla auto paris
lvmh d'avoir permis ce tournage
aujourd'hui
merci de nous avoir suivi sur fear alive
a très vite
[Musique]